when you hear the word urban street what
kind of image comes into mind is it
something like this
no not really how about this yeah this
is more like it right two to four
traffic lanes in the middle two parking
stripes and then two sidewalks shopped
under the buildings this is a typical
street in the developed world in the
21st century but how come urban planning
this radical could become so commonplace
wait what radical yes what you see in
front of you right now is the height of
radicalism it's a type of insanity that
we just all kinda got used to over the
years and never really stopped to
consider its implications it's also a
very recent development yet we all treat
it as if some eternal state of school
now do you see what i'm talking about
let's do it this way for you as a living
breathing human being red is off limits
only green is for you in an urban
settlement built for human beings to
live you as a human being are banned
from most of the public spaces think
about that for a moment let that sink in
inside your city you are banned from
using most public spaces and the only
way you can use those spaces again is if
you purchase a motor vehicle and this is
something very new for as long as human
settlements have existed our streets
used to be places of public congregation
with additional transportation streets
were places for us to socialize to talk
walk drink eat shop hang out in other
words to live our lives this was the
case for thousands of years until about
a hundred years ago the early 20th
century at that point cars started to
become more and more accessible although
nowhere near on today's level the vast
majority of people were not car owners
and they weren't going to be either for
a good while streets were for people
still the vast majority of people but
then something happened something that
was as ingenious as it was sinister an
instance of manufactured consent so well
executed it would put john arbuckle's
1994 to shame and the end result is you
looking out of your window surveying
this radical change this fundamental
shift which is contrary to human nature
and
think nothing of it how did this happen
who was responsible and what can we do
to fix this mess let's find out after a
brief word from today's sponsor
morningbrew morningbrew is a daily
newsletter designed for millennials and
zoomers founded by two students about
half a decade ago morning brew enables
you to keep in touch with the world of
tech startups politics and business
without having to trust through multiple
websites multiple magazines paywalls
warnings to turn off your ad blocker
morningbrew spares you from all that by
providing you a professionally curated
newsletter in it you'll find everything
you need to know that day given to you
in a brief but comprehensive format ah
so harvard said goodbye to fossil
investments huh well better late than
never i guess what's this epic games
going at apple regardless of who loses
here everyone else will win morning brew
lets you keep in touch with the world in
five minutes all your money back well
actually morning brew services are
completely free all you need to do is
type in your email address click the
button and you're done you'll find the
link to the subscription page in my
description below thank you for checking
out morningbrew ads like this helps
support what i do and now back to the
program a hundred or so years ago in the
1920s cars began to appear on the
streets in greater and greater numbers
and by virtue of being a new and
expensive tech novelty it was mostly
wealthy people who owned them and keep
in mind that traffic rules as we know
them today didn't exist yet the way you
drove was completely up to you so we
have a bunch of wealthy [ __ ] in
expensive and fast cars with no traffic
rules driving onto pedestrian streets
and so predictably the result was a
massive death toll the result of a
phenomenon which later came to be called
joyriding and believe it or not the
public was staunchly anti-car at this
point so car manufacturers had a big
problem their cars were being portrayed
as these murderous death machines which
they pretty much were at this point and
the consequences of this bad pr was a
threat to the automaker's bottom line so
what can they do they can't really
change people's minds at this point the
obvious and negative consequences of
motorization were there for anyone to
see and that was when players of the
auto industry came up with an idea an
idea that was just as insidious as it
was genius and effective their targets
became your grandparents or
great-grandparents depending on how old
you are at that point they were school
age still and they started receiving a
new type of education courtesy of the
auto industry and their endless
benevolence for the sake of their safety
children are thought to always look
around before crossing the road because
they are the ones who have to stop for
traffic and not the other way around and
that's because streets belong to cars
not people and so entire generations of
children grew up thinking this was the
new norm but in the meantime the old
generation was very much alive still and
they had some very different ideas about
how streets should be used and they put
up quite the fight against the auto
industry and drivers and they even
scored some victories but according to
peter norton the author of fighting
traffic the dawn of the motor age in the
american city the tide turned against
the majority in 1923 when citizens of
cincinnati organized a referendum aiming
to put governors on cars limiting their
speed to 25 miles per hour and this was
the point when players of the auto
industry decided to go all out they
realized that if this thing gets passed
and becomes a national precedent it'll
become much more difficult to sell cars
and they're gonna make a lot less money
and things went all downhill from there
to quote from this bloomberg article
titled the invention of jaywalking local
auto clubs and dealers sent letters to
every individual with a car in the city
saying the rule would condemn the us to
the fate of china which they painted as
the world's most backward nation they
even hired pretty women to invite men to
head to the polls and vote against the
rule and the measure failed they also
got detroit involved the automakers
banded together to help fight the
cincinnati rule according to norton and
they remained organized after that he
says the industry lobbied to change the
law promoting the adoption of traffic
statues to supplant common law the
statutes were designed to restrict
pedestrian use of the street and give
primacy to cars the idea of jaywalking a
concept that had not really existed
prior to 1920 was enshrined in law and
this is the reason why even today our
streets belong to cars and not people
all of it can be traced back to the auto
industry with corporations using their
wealth and power to subvert the
democratic will of the people even today
in the 21st century our streets are
designed to serve corporate interests
and not the people for the sake of
individualized transport and massive
corporate profits we are forced to
endure all the negative consequences the
traffic hazard the air pollution the
noise pollution the loss of public space
these are all very bad things and guess
who's not suffering from them and over
here we have a picture of inner city
stuttgart germany stuttgart being the
home of daimler group and mercedes-benz
now which one of these buildings do you
think the daimler leadership lives in i
mean hey this looks like the ideal place
for a car company's leadership there's
like 14 traffic lanes all very close to
the buildings now this might come as a
shock for you but they seem to prefer
different areas of the city and over
here we can see the dagalok and waldow
areas of stuttgart in these places and
the areas near them your average size
nothing special single-family homes cost
between one and three million dollars
according to this local german newspaper
this is one of the most expensive areas
of stuttgart offering its tenants calm
and quiet and proximity to green areas
and the city center they also describe
it as a practical daimler enclave
but hey if you also want to raise your
children in an area free of the negative
aspects of motorization all you need to
do is buy a house in waldow that would
be 1.2 million dollars please if you're
lucky and this is the reason why i
fundamentally oppose urban motorization
it produces this bizarre and harmful
hierarchy where the wealthy in our
society can pay money for things such as
clean air calm and quiet access to green
areas and streets on which their
children can safely play all these used
to be the standard for most people in
cities now they come at a seven digit
premium but health space and
environmental consequences are not the
only ones we suffer from there is also a
social aspect also known as atomization
as i've mentioned before streets used to
be places of public congregation and
socialization right until cars took it
over and it was kobe 19 that really
highlighted this problem as soon as we
didn't have the restaurants the bars the
clubs the yoga classes many people
became completely isolated with no
opportunities to meet others before the
era of motorization you would have known
people from the street people living in
your neighborhood that is because
streets were places to hang out in to
stroll around to do your thing to have
conversations with people to socialize
but nowadays with all the noise the
pollution the crammed narrow sidewalks
streets became this temporary
unpleasantness that we have to trudge
through to get to the nice places and
all because we gave our streets to cars
so what is the solution how do we fix
this mess one word superblocks to date
superblocks are the most efficient ways
of taking back our neighborhoods and
making our streets fit for human
habitation once again the first
superblock was established in barcelona
spain in 2016 and it turned out to be a
massive success so much so that now they
are being expanded here's how it works
you take an area delimited by four major
roads and inside that area you
pedestrianize every single street of
course residence cars and essential
services can still drive in but the
streets are arranged in a way that you
cannot go through the area that means
you will only drive into the superblock
if you really have business there the
philosophy of this design is that inside
a superblock cars are only guests living
inside a superblock encourages a more
active healthier lifestyle which reduces
obesity diabetes and other similar
health issues people will also live
longer and healthier lives because of
the lack of noise and air pollution with
superblocks a tremendous amount of
public space is freed up again providing
people with much needed places of public
congregation this reduces loneliness and
thus increases mental health superblocks
seem to be a great solution to all the
problems brought about by mass
motorization so let's build more right
now vienna is also joining this club
with their first experimental superblock
oh i mean supergretzel which is great in
the meantime paris has been doing a ton
of stuff already banning through traffic
from the center pedestrianizing the
pomonads the list goes on now i think
every major city should start doing this
right now not only because it's a nice
and beneficial thing to do but also
because pretty soon we'll have to do it
due to this thing called the oncoming
climate catastrophe where cities by 2050
will see a temperature increase of up to
80 degrees celsius in their maximum
temperature holy [ __ ] and if this
happens which it really looks like it
will all our big black asphalt cover
streets will turn into frying pans
imagine hearing that your dog got hit by
a car but upon running out to the street
only finding a piece of well done steak
the only way cities will be able to
combat this temperature increase the
only way our cities will remain livable
is through narrow streets with lots of
shading no black asphalt and certainly
no giant hunks of metal and plastic to
absorb all the heat so yeah essentially
climate resistant superblocks and better
sooner than later and this can be
achieved by banning most motor traffic
inside cities and giving back public
spaces to the people and wouldn't that
be nice to sum up if you hate hierarchy
and dying of complications from heat
strokes you should support transitioning
away from individual motor traffic and i
know that for some of you this might
have sounded a bit radical or harsh but
i'm sorry we have no choice since
apparently we kind of just gave up on
stopping extreme climate change the
least we can do is prepare for the
consequences right at any rate thank you
for watching and please like and
subscribe and don't forget to check out
my patreon if you think this content is
worth your money and vote for
politicians who are in favor of the
congestion measures please
and i'll be seeing you next time